fun really is he something wanted to
citizen balancing universe hey everybody
we got some new infinity war to break
down but because of the way it dropped
that to be a little creative about how I
break it down so I had to cut this up
just a little bit differently than I
normally would but they've already
started dropping Easter eggs for
infinity war and if you're a big fan of
the other stuff the Russos have done
like Arrested Development and community
there are actually some really funny
Easter eggs for that in the infinity war
trailer so I'll point them out when we
get to that part but if you are finding
me for the first time we do Marvel every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's even a ticket
giveaway I'm doing at the end of the
video I'll explain but what's happened
is is because they're pretty much done
with the Infinity war trailer it started
to post online so I'll just do this and
try to connect the dots in terms of time
frames because of the vignettes it's
hard to tell when these are gonna take
place during the movie because you have
Captain America Scarlet Witch vision
stuff going on on earth then you have
guardians of the galaxy stuff happening
in a different part of space so they're
just a bunch of different groups of
people so we can guess at what the
timeline is from some of these scenes
but it's not gonna be a hundred percent
starting with the stuff based on earth
first very clearly it's Proxima midnight
in Corvus glaive coming after the mine
gem so they're coming after vision and
the other Avengers that are nearby are
trying to protect him so even though
they revealed what the Black Order looks
like they're calling them the children
of Thanos which I'll explain you know
what they've changed from the comics in
a second but this is the actual first
time that we've seen her with finished
CG on screen they'll probably polish
this a little bit but for the most part
this is what she will look like during
the movie so the spear that she wields
was given to her by Thanos it's a
mythical weapon that reads a lot like
the creation of Thor's hammer just in
the scope of what it can actually do so
it was created from a son trapped in
distorted space-time and what it does is
it acts like a star a supernova in a
black hole all at the same time when she
throws it it gives off energy arcs but
it also is able to increase its mass
because remember it acts kind of like a
supernova so it becomes super dense and
it would be like Surtur destroying
guard with his giant Twilight sword but
in the size of this small spear she
throws it at Captain America he catches
it but then you jump to a couple of
different scenes you see Falcon trying
to fight her off so even though there's
no way that Falcon would have a chance I
think they want to give him some badass
scenes so then you jumped all those
Scarlet Witch scenes looking like she's
trying to protect vision although vision
is also one of the most powerful members
but I think he's just getting tag-teamed
by Proxima midnight in Corvus glaive who
may have the same implied relationship
that they do in the comics in the comics
they're husband and wife but in the
movie universe they're the children of
Thanos so it's kind of a weird situation
but if they're gonna do the Scarlet
Witch vision relationship thing which
I'll talk about in a separate video then
they might as well tease some Corvus
glaive Proxima midnight relationship but
like you see vision here behind these
bars the entrance to the subway looking
like he's kind of relieved like oh my
god I just survived that it's possible
that because of the way Scarlet Witch is
looking at him they are able to fight
them off and Thanos doesn't get the gem
that way because it does sound like
vision we'll make it to Avengers 4 and
they're doing this really weird thing
with their children from the comics but
that's all still speculation based on
some casting announcements they've made
for Avengers 4 so vision is still status
pending but I think he will survive to
the next phase of Marvel movies in some
form or another but then you get the
crowd shot a black widow Falcon in
Captain America which actually looks
like when the black order first arrives
like they're watching them land in their
ship like holy here we go so it's
before all of these big fight scenes but
even though Scarlet Witch is destroying
a whole bunch of property here I think
the idea is is that as the movies have
gotten on their powers have grown like
the powers of the infinity gems are
limitless or near limitless and they've
only begun to tap them as of Captain
America Civil War and like you saw her
throw down and smashed vision through
all those floors imagine how much more
powerful she is by the time we get to
infinity war but then all the other
scenes our guardians of the galaxy
specific scenes set in the collectors
fortress where Thanos has taken down the
collector and is trying to find the
reality stone and he's trying to tell
him I sold it to someone else I don't
know where it is I don't have it but you
can kind of see this motion capture foot
on his chest so obviously they haven't
completely finished this yeah
but is awesome and WTF is this is they
also work a lot of comedic scenes into
this too like Peter quill trying to be
all ninja and then you see mantis like
just shuffling by as quietly as possible
Drax totally ready to botch the mission
and try to go after Thanos now is when I
seek my revenge for the death of my
family that's actually a deep cut from
the comics they mentioned it during the
first Guardians movie but he just had
this long-standing hatred of Thanos and
had been seeking revenge ever since he
had come to Drax's planet and killed his
family in a big assault so if they don't
pay that moment up here there will be
some other moment during infinity war
where do they let them face off but I
think the idea is as if Thanos is so
powerful that he will roll into Avengers
4 with most of the gems and The Avengers
will just be shattered so even if he
doesn't wind up finding the gem here he
finds out where it is and destroys this
entire fortress so that's why you see
all this wreckage here you may have
spotted the Arrested Development Easter
egg like I said there's gonna be a lot
of jokes in here too it's gonna be
really serious because of the subject
matter but there will be plenty of funny
Easter eggs so the Russos directed
Arrested Development so naturally they
work some of that into the movie itself
in the background here you can see that
the collector has collected Tobias while
he's turned himself into one of the
people from Blue Man Group if you don't
remember that is probably one of the
funniest scenes from Arrested
Development but just expect a lot more
of that during infinity war like little
Easter eggs probably some cameos from
people that were in community while the
Russos were still directing that the
really big stuff that's missing from
this is all the Iron Man Spider Man
scenes they sort of come as a package
but we get to see spider-man spidey
sense for the first time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe technically he didn't
have it during spider-man homecoming we
get to see the new versions of their
suits but we finally get to see Winter
Soldier thawed out in Wakanda remains to
be seen who they're going to be fighting
but I guess it's gonna be black dwarf
just because he's so ferocious such a
brawler and that's kind of who black
panther is so it makes sense that they
would pair them up then there's also
footage of ebony maw coming for Doctor
Strange to get the Time gem which is
also an easter egg for the infinity art
and we haven't talked about it in a
while but remember nebula explained what
their upbringing was like the children
of Thanos were forced to fight each
other so she and Gamora would get body
parts for
to make them stronger if they lost any
of the fights but the thing is is that
we didn't learn about the other children
the other children that they grew up
with are the black order of this movie
so if you've read the comics you know
that they come from a different place
and they didn't debut till much much
later after the Thanos quest Infinity
Gauntlet storyline so the sort of mixing
and matching the modern stuff in the
classic stuff just to give fan oohs his
own dark version of the Avengers but
even though they've tweaked their origin
they're pretty accurate to what their
abilities are what their powers are if
you saw the comic-con trailer then
you'll probably recognize a lot of these
scenes so it looks like the official
trailer will be a slightly bigger
version of the comic-con trailer with
better footage but let me know in the
comments what do you think about all
this what's your favorite moment and
what other Easter eggs are you hoping to
find obviously there's gonna be a bunch
of Easter eggs for Thanos quest but as
you can see they work in Arrested
Development Easter eggs so it's gonna go
beyond the Marvel Universe but as far as
I know the official trailer is supposed
to drop next week so whenever that
happens or if it drops early I'll
totally do a video for it but leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below I'll probably do more
videos for the Black Order once we get
better footage of them and then we could
talk about the timeline between the Thor
Ragnarok post-credit scene where Thanos
ship shows up and then what's happening
during this trailer but there's a new
round of the IMAX ticket giveaway
because there's a whole bunch of stuff
coming out it's just for any movie that
you want all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I'll announce a new winner
when I post new Marvel and while you
wait for everything you can click here
for that brand new black panther trailer
and you can click here for the trailer
for the big four-way crossover thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight